But they know that if they dare step up
and fight the monster, well,
the monster will come for them.
Just broadly on Jordan, the
best thing that I can say about
Jordan, so we did about
110 stops in a year
it was incredible, we went
to dozens of countries.
Truly the best thing that
I can say about Jordan is
he is the real deal.
I have never met someone in this space
that the exact man that you guys know
that you watch these videos of is
the exact guy the second
the cameras go off.
I never saw him be rude
to anyone anywhere.
I mean, try to imagine
the amount of people
that would come up to us everywhere,
airports, bathrooms, restaurants.
All the time, it's a minute before a show,
he's running late stop,
ask them how they're doing,
what their name is.
And the other thing,
and this is probably more important.
I never saw him break one of the 12 rules.
He had many opportunities
that he could have lied
to somebody about how I can't talk
'cause I got to go or whatever.
He never broke one of the 12 rules.
And as a matter of fact,
there was one night
some of you guys may
have seen the picture.
We were in London and Jordan and I
and Modularize, you
probably know had dinner
at Douglas Murray's flat.
That's apartment in London East.
And we had dinner there.
And one of the rules, is the 12th rule?
Maybe the 11th rule about petting a cat,
if you see one on the street,
and it really what he's saying there is
don't forget to stop and smell the roses.
So Douglas had a cat, and
we're in there for about
three hours, we're eating, we're drinking.
We're having a great
time and I noticed about
three, four hours in and I
had had plenty of drinks.
I was like, I don't think
Jordan has pet this cat.
And I was like, if he
doesn't pet this cat,
the guy's a fraud like.
(audience laughs)
Then we're like five
hours in I'm really drunk.
And I'm like, I couldn't
stop thinking about it.
Like if he doesn't pet
this cat like I'm on tour
with the biggest fraud in
the history of the world.
Anyway, we're saying our goodbyes,
Jordan gets on the ground
and Jordan is really tall
and like, he gets on the ground
and sits with the cat basically
sitting in the cats bed,
just like little flatbed.
And just, I mean, you can picture
it because you can sort of
picture Jordan's hands
and just petting, petting,
petting the cat and I thought,
all right, the gig goes on.
We're gonna be okay.
(audience laughs)
Yeah, he's a great guy.
And he's the real deal
and he's serious about his ideas
and I'm a better person for
having done the tour truly.
- Yeah, good for you.
The thing that fascinates me,
I see this a lot when
people have opinions.
It's very easy to, what's I should say
it's difficult to state an opinion
that you know is gonna
be against the grain.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- And that I wouldn't
say it's controversial,
the person saying it feels it
or knows it as fact, believes it is fact.
And then they kind of stop.
And I think that's just one other note,
I want to make an
interview where it's like,
he would say something and stop,
and it's just so not accepted in society
to say some of the things
he would say, without like,
but this and this, or I believe this.
That's an opinion.
I mean, he just would say it.
- Well, the irony, of course,
was that every time the media
would try to sandbag him
and try to destroy him,
which we saw many times,
you guys may remember
that one of the biggest moments
was when the New York
Times wrote that piece
that Jordan is for enforced monogamy.
Remember that, and everyone
made it sound like he wants
to basically make women slaves
and we're gonna be in the handmaid's tale.
Enforced monogamy just means marriage.
If you look actually
Eric Weinstein checked
and on the New York Times archives,
the only other two references
to enforce monogamy
or positive references about marriage.
That marriage is a
fundamental building block
for a Western society.
It causes us to reproduce
and have familial bonds
and all of these things.
But the more they attacked him,
by him just keeping his cool
and this is a good lesson
for any of you guys,
if you're ever gonna be brave enough
to say anything you believe in,
the more they attacked him,
the more he stood his ground.
And he would say by nature,
I'm not a combative person.
And that's hard to believe
when you see these people,
they're in these fights constantly.
But he would stand his
ground say what he believes
and say simple truths.
I'm not against trans people,
but the government can't tell
me what to call somebody.
I'm for marriage.
I mean, basic stuff.
And if you do that, and
you don't lose your cool,
well, everyone, he's
a worldwide phenomenon
and those things go hand in hand.
- Yeah.
So I want to go back to
we talked free speech,
kind of as a broad term,
but I want to talk specifically
a lot of the students in the
room and kind of this campus
culture of free speech,
you see a lot of comedians
that won't go to campus just
because of some of the backlash
and the current environment
that's been created.
So one of the things that
I really think is missing
amongst the libertarian
conservative crowd,
is this idea that we continue
to say campuses biased,
campus shuts down our speakers,
they don't recognize our
student organizations.
They don't let us get rooms,
to actually have have
speakers or meetings.
But then we don't do anything about it.
And about three, almost
four years ago now,
we launched a program called
the National Fight for
Free Speech Campaign,
with the idea of saying,
let's stop just complaining.
Let's figure out what
are these bureaucrats
and the college administrators doing
to shut down our groups
or to shut down speakers
and you have certain campuses
need to get a permission slip
to go out and do activism
and talk to people.
A lot of them will charge
the outrageous security fee,
- That's the new one, yeah.
- to bring the speaker
throughout the campus.
And I love that you say
that it's the new one
because what happens is,
and these are typically,
liberal campus bureaucrats,
somebody tries a new code
or new policy and it works,
then all of a sudden you see
other people picking it up.
When we're trying to combat them,
we will try to purposefully do an event
that is against the code.
So let's say they have these
free speech zones, right?
They say, okay, listen,
it's a public school.
We're supposed to uphold
the First Amendment,
but just to protect everyone.
We have a small zone to size of,
let's say, an iPhone on a tennis court,
- Yeah.
- right if that's the campus,
and this is were able to speak freely.
Well, we will purposefully
do an event outside of it.
And it's funny, we used
to do a free speech wall.
The university said it's
a fire hazard, right?
I mean, they're very smart.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- I mean nicely smart,
these administrators,
so then we to push back
now we do have free speech,
beach balls, these giant beach
balls roll around campus,
but we do these events,
but it's crazy to me
that college administrators
will shut down.
Not controversial opinion.
I mean, they do that and I don't believe
they should be doing that.
But we have students who have handed out
pocket constitutions,
they've gotten arrested
and put in jail.
The document literally
has the First Amendment
written in it.
So what do you think is?
(Dave and the audience laughs)
What do you think has caused
this authoritarian belief
and do you really think
it's that administrators
want to protect students now?
- No.
- Or is it more of a control thing.
- No it's neither,
it's actually it goes back to the core of
what I talked about are
the factory settings
before and it goes back
to what has happened
with the modern left that in academia
more than anywhere else.
I mean, this is where this whole horrible
set of ideas of post modernism took root
and all of these people
know the administrators
and the faculty know if they dare
except with a few exceptions,
University Chicago is pretty good on it.
And there's a couple other schools
that are fighting for speech.
But they know as an administrator
that if they dare stand up
and defend Ben Shapiro's
ability to come to a school,
I mean, look, the idea that Shapiro,
whatever you guys disagree
with him about is fine.
The idea that he's a controversial speaker
is completely bananas.
Shapiro, probably, I
would guess, agrees with,
policies of Ronald Reagan, probably 99%.
Now, you may not like some of
those policies, that's fine.
But the point is that it was
mainstream conservative thought
only 25, 30 years ago,
something like that.
But they know that if they dare step up
and fight the monster, well,
the monster will come for them.
So that also goes back to why I know
that Bernie will eventually
be eaten by this thing.
It's a constant movement of destruction.
It's not about creation.
There was a video I'm sure
some of you guys saw this.
I spoke at the University of New Hampshire
it has a couple million views
and before the event, right before the end
about an hour before they said
"we can't secure a room on campus"
apparently I'm so controversial
that they could not secure a room.
Now, so they had to take it off site.
So we had maybe 400 students there.
So and it was sold out
for the size of that room
it was 400 people in a 400 person room,
there were more people that want to get in
and couldn't get in.
But then they said we
can't secure the room.
So they moved us to the local hockey rink,
which sat 10,000 people.
So I spoke for 400 people
in a 10,000 seat arena,
which is extremely bizarre,
but I don't bring that up
because I'm talking about
the numbers as much as
they already said we lost.
If a university says we cannot
even secure our own campus,
they have already lost and
then the protesters come in
and they scream that
I'm not for free speech
or I'm a bigot and a
Nazi in the rest of it.
One of the girls kept
calling me a homophobe,
which my husband has no idea.
(audience claps and cheers)
And the best part of that one
and if you haven't seen this,
it's on YouTube, just search Dave Rubin,
New Hampshire.
There was a woman in
the back screaming at me
that I hate trans people.
She kept saying I hate trans people.
So I said, I just want
to be very clear about
my feelings towards trans people.
I want them to be treated
with the exact same dignity
and respect and the under the same laws
that everyone else has to be.
I said specifically to her,
I made sure to look at her, I said,
I hope that you have someone
that you love in your life
and you found happiness
and all of these things.
And then she called me Hitler and the Nazi
and all that blah, blah, blah.
But the best part of this,
I did not know this till weeks later.
It turns out that she was
a gender studies professor
at the University.
I mean, really, when you
think about how deeply corrupt
so you have a faculty
member of a really made up,
it's not a real set of ideas, right?
It's not.
(audience claps and cheers)
It could have just as easily
been an economics professor
or whatever else, the idea
that they are literally
they're shouting down speakers.
And I'm not, I don't
want you guys to mob her
or anyone else watching this to mob her
it doesn't even matter.
It would be nice, I suppose
if the students of the school
did something but that
she felt empowered enough
because of her place in
the intersection of scale,
that she knew she could go to an event,
scream down to a speaker
try to silence a speaker
and know that she'd
have complete impunity.
And no matter what I said,
I mean, that's the other thing.
I offered her every piece of
goodness that I had to say,
I don't know what our
differences are exactly,
but I certainly don't hate you.
I certainly don't hate anyone
because of their identity.
But that's the weird
state that they were in
and I suppose that it'll
probably keep getting worse
because I don't know if this,
but we're in an election year
and we ain't seen nothing yet.
Nice man that was really fun.
If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of non stop yelling,
check out our politics playlist
and if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.